hello vaxxers and unvaxers
and non-disclosed i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report direct message today
is october 13th
2021 share subscribe tap the
notification bell yada yada four stories
for you today i am feeling very on point
so uh make sure you're you know really
sat tightly in your seat don't want you
falling out of the chair over there uh
obviously we've got some covid stuff but
actually a couple stories that are kinda
good you're not gonna believe it a
couple stories that are actually pretty
decent and showing that good people are
standing up including one from here in
crazy california where the police chief
isn't going to force his officers to do
things that they don't want to do i know
it's crazy radical right-wing stuff but
it's happening even here in the banana
city of los angeles cnn then even put on
two doctors who said that we shouldn't
have vaccine mandates to fly is the
whole system breaking down what the high
hell is going on we'll discuss
story number two we've got three clips
of
the white house chief liar jen saki the
woman who could not say a true statement
of her life depended on it as i always
say if you asked her her favorite
color she would say four i mean the
woman is incapable of saying anything
honest we've got three clips of her
lying or otherwise obfuscating the truth
there's your word of the day then i saw
a clip this morning on twitter from
msnbc have you heard about this network
if you pretend when you're watching it
that they're all broadcasting from a
mental institution it's actually quite
entertaining but there's this woman
tiffany cross who i guess has a show
there i've never heard of her before
before i saw this clip this morning and
from the little clip that i saw she
might be more insane than joy reid so
we've got to discuss that and speaking
of insanity we've got something from
hillary clinton too so four stories for
you and before i get to all that oh
and big news you know yesterday and
thank you all by the way for the emails
of concern
about my producer michael it is true
that on sunday he did have the sniffles
fair to say i believe that was your word
the sniffles you had the sniffles and uh
he did not come into work yesterday he
worked from home yesterday had the
sniffles has less sniffles today we you
felt he said it was an acceptable level
of sniffles we discussed it connor was
in on it we had a team meeting are we to
sit with this guy in this room we can
confirm he does not have covid we can
also confirm that i did not force a free
man in the united states of america to
inject himself with anything against his
will and things are moving forward here
nobody died big show today big show all
right before we get to all that though
guys i wanted and congratulations again
on life michael very excited i want to
talk to you guys about black rifle
coffee you know they're a veteran-owned
coffee company that serves premium
coffee to people who love america i'm
drinking it right now in their fancy mug
they develop their explosive roast
profiles with the same mission focus
they learned as military members serving
with this great country with every
purchase you make they give back in 2020
they donated over 6 million cups of
coffee to veteran law enforcement and
first responder causes black rifle
coffee company imports high quality
coffee beans from colombia and brazil
and roasts five days a week from their
facilities in manchester tennessee and
salt lake city utah the best way to
enjoy their freedom-filled coffee is by
subscribing to the black rifle coffee
club when you join the club your chosen
brew is roasted packaged and shipped
free to your door on your schedule and
you also receive special discounted
pricing on various roasts and gain
access to exclusive products member only
content partner discounts and more i
always get excited when i see a new bag
has arrived they send me these bags that
are freaking huge with temperatures
cooling off don't let that stop you from
getting outside and into the great
outdoors with signature roasts like lava
panther medium roast which is directly
sourced farm to cup from a small farm in
guatemala black rifle coffee company
delivers fresh roast coffee from around
the world directly to your doorstep
purchase at blackriflecoffee.com
ruben and use code ruben at checkout for
20 off your first purchase including
your coffee club order that's
blackriflecoffee.comruben
and now back to me all right guys we got
a jam packed show for you and you know
i'm always talking to you guys about we
need to see that star in the distance
right we need to see some
hope as we are just constantly
being sort of enveloped under this
avalanche of nonsense that our
politicians and our media are pushing on
us all the time well i've actually got
good news today and not only do i have
good news i have good news from los
angeles
could this be true could it actually be
happening could something decent be
emanating from this hellscape that i
live in well la sheriff alex villanueva
is saying that he's not going to enforce
vaccine mandates on his staff because
you're not going to believe this some of
the people don't want to do it and he'd
like to have police officers to stop
what's that thing that they usually do
they stop uh crime right crime take a
look are you forcing your officers to
set the vaccine to get the vaccine as i
said no i'm not forcing anyone the
issues become so politicized
their entire groups of employees and are
willing to be fired and laid off rather
than get vaccinated so
i don't want to be in a position to lose
five ten percent of my workforce
overnight on a mac vaccine mandate
while the same time our bare bones
with uh the funding effort so this is
like the worst of two worlds right here
so we have to pick and choose
it's not that often i get to say
something good about la it's not that
often i get to show you a public servant
who is a decent human being but there's
one right there he's not going to force
his people to do it he understands that
police officers have a job say stop you
know uh murdering right like someone's
coming to murder someone a police
officer might get involved in that
someone would say robbing a store or
breaking into your house or trying to
rape someone these are things that
police officers are supposed to take
care of and they usually do a pretty
decent job of it and despite the fact
that the media treats them horribly and
you know the entire sort of leftist
machinery in the country vilifies them
at every opportunity that they get so
not only does he say he's not going to
force these guys to do it which by the
way then they can make the choices for
themselves and you know if you're a
police officer and you're concerned
about covid you can get vaccinated you
can get boosted up the wazoo and then if
one of your co-police officers has covid
well i was told and you know me i just
believe whatever anyone says i was told
a while back that the vaccine stops
coving now they've sort of shifted off
that but he's allowing people to make
choices for themselves by the way most
police officers they're somewhere
probably between early 20s
and say late 40s something like that so
you know they're they're relatively
young they probably
are somewhat fit not all of them we've
we've all seen the guys at the donut
shop but i stand with the police
officers i certainly stand with alex
villanueva and it's just nice to see
something out of that out of la that's
good oh and by the way he said at the
end there because we're also dealing
with the defunding thing right because
we've got this bananas mayor here and
this authoritarian lunatic governor who
are still
trying to take funds away from policing
and you guys know we've covered these
stories many times in every single city
without exception no exceptions
when they've taken money away from
policing you're not going to believe
this crime has gone up
isn't that weird it's weird how
sometimes things like that happen you
take policing away you say to people oh
you could do certain crimes certain
trespassing's okay stealing a certain
amount of stuff is okay jumping some
turnstiles is okay you know loitering
that sort of that's all okay you know
punch a random guy on the street i'm
sure you had your reasons uh crime
starts going up so that is a good man
right there and speaking of good men i
don't even know how this happened cnn
had two people on that did not ring the
bananas alarm about covet and actually
said they should not have vaccine
mandates on airlines today is it bizarro
day what day is today today's bizarro
day take a look it's a complicated issue
i i don't believe uh we should uh and
and the reason is this particularly for
air travel air travel is safe it's not
for the protection of the people on the
plane it's just another way to sort of
force people to do their vaccine so i
don't think that's justified and it will
really hurt the industry and travel
do you agree
well i think he's exactly correct the
travel itself being on the aircraft is a
is at exceedingly low risk particularly
if everybody keeps their masks on and so
that's not the issue it's just another
device to get people vaccinated so i
wouldn't single out that industry in
particular to make sure all of its
customers are vaccinated
i don't know what the high hills going
on here maybe i woke up on another
planet or something or i'm actually in a
coma right now and i'm going through
some sort of uh you know psychotropic
trip something like that they're going
to wake me up in a second they'd go no
no dave you're actually in gulag 13b uh
but look two people one was a former uh
trump administration official and uh and
the doctor right there and you could
tell that man was a doctor because he
was wearing a white coat and i don't
know what else where you could get a
white coat if you're not a doctor but
what he said was really interesting
exceedingly low risk of getting coveted
on a plane
so why would you force people to be
vaccinated to get on a plane he said it
it's just another device to get people
vaccinated that's and we know that to be
true i keep talking about this every
time you get on a plane they show you a
video they've got people in masks and
hazmat suits although they're usually uh
they sometimes they have like some sort
of
see-through thing on you can see them
with their freakish smile as they're
spraying the place down right and
they've got that special green gun
they're spraying there's no microbes
everywhere here we've handed you some
cleaner thing to rip open and clean your
seat when you sit down we have no
evidence but please correct me if i'm
wrong that covet is spreading on
airplanes right so they're telling us
these are the safest things we filter
the air it cleans out
99.99999 percent of germs
so i don't know what just happened but
cnn suddenly doing something actually
honest that the only reason you would be
for
a vaccine mandate to get on a plane is
only if you want to use the bat against
the leg of the unvaccinated person if
you wanted to say to that unvaccinated
person nope in effect you can just never
leave
your state again you should just stay at
home forever and by the way i'm gonna
stop saying this but you can do whatever
the [ __ ] you want i don't care you can
do it and wear a mask and inject
yourself in all of those things it's up
to you but anyway i i'm shocked we've
got police officers in l.a standing up
for the right thing we've got people on
cnn saying something true
is i'm actually
it's incredible it's absolutely
incredible let's uh let's move on though
and and speaking of truth now i'm going
to show you things that aren't true and
if you want to sort of just do a daily
video collection on someone constantly
lying and completely incapable of saying
the truth you just find a jen saki clip
she's the white house press secretary
she gets up there she lies about
absolutely everything i would say it's a
combination of intentional lying partly
it's what her job is press secretary
you're supposed to be deflecting all the
time and then it's that i also think
she's either slightly brain dead or
something's not right there because i
just don't know what could you have a
soul if you were just like lying
constantly like that so maybe she's just
not that bright i'm trying to give her
the benefit now
first off here she is on forcing vaccine
vaccine mandates on the states these
requirements are promulgated by federal
law so when the president announced
his
vaccine
mandates for businesses that of course
were waiting on osha regulations for as
a next step
that was pursuant to federal law and the
implementation of federal law because
it's an executive order so our intention
is to implement and continue to work to
implement these requirements across the
country including in the states where
there are attempts to oppose them
okay so she's intentionally conflating
issues there which is where her lie sits
so yes there is an executive order
saying that if you work for the federal
government or if you work as a
contractor for a federal government
meaning you know you sell
ice cream to the federal government that
you have to be vaccinated your employees
have to be vaccinated i'm obviously not
for any of that at any level but that
part of what she's saying is true where
she's confusing things is that the rest
of it basically are guidelines it's a
press release there is no law executive
order or otherwise that is demanding
that companies of a hundred plus people
force people to be vaccinated
must force people to be vaccinated
obviously she knows that she absolutely
knows that but she's purposely confusing
it right that's what she's purposely
doing and also implying that the states
don't have as much authority as they
actually do because the federal
government should reign supreme over
everything else she actually went
further into that right here going back
to texas um
what is the president's message to
businesses in texas you mentioned
several of them who are based there
when it comes to what the federal
guidance is now now with the state
executive order what would the president
say to those companies as they're
determining what they should be doing
right now for the vaccine mandates well
we know uh that federal law uh overrides
state law i would note that
earlier when we put out our guidance on
the president's
announcement about mandates several
weeks ago he made clea it made clear
that
again as i said earlier requirements are
promulgated pursuant to federal law and
supersede any contrary state or local
law or ordinance
additionally nothing in this guidance
excuses non-compliance with any
applicable state law or municipal
ordinance we put out guidance several
weeks ago conveying that clearly but
fundamentally beyond the legal aspect
which is unquestionable in our view
the question for any business leader is
what do you want to do to save more
lives in your companies
okay so there's so many lies and
confusions in there first off she is
telling you the truth when she says this
thing about we put out guidance yes
guidance not a law but her implication
is oh we the federal government put out
guidance so you the states have to do
what we say no that's not true now it is
slightly true what she said that usually
when the states and the federal
government are in conflict with one
another usually the federal government
power overrides it not always by the way
if you want a very simple example of
this of what's happening in the states
right now versus federal power uh you
know in certain states right now
california one of them colorado um i
think uh where else is marijuana legal
give me a couple states washington yeah
a couple other states um
actually if you go to new york city
right now when i went back a couple
weeks ago all the corners that i used to
walk by that would always smell like
urine they actually all smell like
marijuana now i'm not sure if that's
better or worse but in any event
federally marijuana is illegal but
states have made the decision to make it
illegal not illegal right they've made
it legal so in essence the states are
doing something and the feds know that
it's federally illegal but they're not
doing anything about it actually every
now and again i hate to tell you this
but that barack obama guy remember that
picture of him smoking a doobie from way
back when he used to use the fed every
now and again to close marijuana stores
here in los angeles okay so the point is
there is some tension between the
federal government and states government
but what she's saying there that
unquestionably
the federal government is uh is more
powerful and has to bow
that the states have to bow to the
federal government it's absolutely a lie
by the way we have something called the
constitution you guys remember the
constitution right and these bill bill
of rights they're quite fascinating and
they uh illuminate certain rights that
we have to make sure that the government
never becomes too powerful i'd like to
sum up the 10th amendment to you and
really listen to this the powers not
delegated to the united states by the
constitution nor prohibited by it to the
states are reserved to the states
respectively or
to the people
in other words federal law does not
always overpower state law if something
is not specifically delineated to the
federal law
then the states are allowed to make
their own choices this is where we'll
end up probably in court with a lot of
these things but there is nothing
legally wrong with what greg abbott did
and if you're in texas and you're upset
about your governor giving you too much
freedom you should move to california
now ironically no one's moving to
california right we know california had
its first net loss of population in 2020
in the first
for the first time in the history of the
state it'll probably happen for the
second time when we get the numbers on
2021. so she's lying there because she's
saying that basically a press release
and guidance overruns states and when
she says unquestionably it's like these
people are ripping the mask off and
really telling you who they are
we have all the power
it doesn't matter where you live we're
gonna make you do what we want you to do
and this gets to one of the things that
i've been talking about now for a couple
of months which is what are the people
going to do who just want to be left
alone who just care about local
government
and at that to that end don't even want
local government to be that powerful but
just want to live in a city that's along
the lines of what they believe in and a
broader sense that in a state
and have laws and vote for people in
their own local community that will
protect them and their family and just
not be too involved if the federal
government is ever encroaching and
that's why
to me you don't have to be a republican
i don't consider myself a republican in
any sort of traditional sense but you
cannot be a democrat anymore if you're a
sane person every single thing that
these people say is about taking more
money taking more power and taking more
control
from you and and over your life and
there that is exactly what they're
saying and if you don't believe that
that what they are here to do is
fundamentally change the united states
right remember biden was campaigning on
i'm the guy that's the moderate here
bernie's the bananas guy uh he's gonna
burn it all down i'm just joe biden i've
been doing this for 47 years you know me
come on man i'm joe biden graham popcorn
pop the whole thing uh but if you don't
think
that they're here to destroy everything
and biden is just the the vessel
ushering it in listen to what saki said
about the economy yesterday president
doesn't prefer then one avenue or the
other
the president wants to make fundamental
change in our economy and he feels
coming out of the pandemic is exactly
the time to do that and if we don't do
it now if we don't address
uh the cost of child care to go back to
josh's question earlier if we don't
address the climate crisis if we don't
ensure that universal pre-k is a reality
now
uh
we're not going to have the same
opportunity to do it for some time
did you catch that i'll read you the
quote the president wants to make
fundamental change in our economy
maybe to like a more socialist economy
because that's kind of what he's doing
did anyone vote for that did you
moderates did you good liberals
to do good bill maher liberals is that
what you voted for a fundamental
changing of the economy which is
obviously by extension a fundamental
transforming of everything that america
is all about but they're telling you
they're telling you we don't care about
states rights we're going to
fundamentally change the economy by the
way we flag posts for facebook to take
down when we don't like what you know
those peons are saying these are the bad
guys guys they are
i'm sorry they they just absolutely are
what is it that he wants to change the
economy to accomplish well he wants more
child care okay all right i guess i mean
i don't think the state should have
anything to do with that at this point
the state doesn't do anything well why
would you trust the state with your
children we better do something on
climate change yeah as if there aren't
enough problems here and now right we
got uh bananas aoc with her green new
deal or you know the world's going to
end in 12 years and then universal pre-k
i mean it gets again to the the child
care thing it's like they want to scare
you to the point that they will put your
children
in masks while prison guards don't have
to be in masks and vaccinated and
everything else but we've got to get
these children brainwashed as quickly as
possible and just let's see how much
free crap
we can give people so that they keep
voting for us let's just see what we can
do so yes i believe people when they say
it so when they say that they want to
fundamentally change the economy
fundamentally change the united states
when they say that they they think the
whole thing is racist when they say that
you know
that the fundamental
founding of america is evil and all of
those things i kind of believe them i
don't like them but i do believe them
speaking of people i don't like i don't
even know of this person but i don't
like her this tiffany cross on msnbc
i've never heard of her until this
morning i saw this clip
i don't know is she does she host a
regular show or she was a guest host is
it is a regular show i'm not even sure
but she went on a highly racist rant
this morning
completely racist rant so i'm gonna play
her racist rant and i want you to think
as you're watching this rant have you
ever heard anything this racist
on on fox news because i'm guessing you
haven't here we go
okay carlos watson sade steele
van jones what do these three folks have
in common well they're all people who
have been prompted up by wealthy or
powerful white americans and yet we the
keepers of the culture don't really rock
with any of them like that now obviously
the three of these folks are most
definitely black faces however they are
not necessarily black voices and there's
a difference let me explain take a
listen to these half-witted self-hating
remarks from state still
barack obama chose black and he's
biracial i'm like well congratulations
to the president that's his thing i
think that's fascinating considering
considering
his black dad was nowhere to be found
but his white mom and grandma raised him
but hey you do you
what
so that is undoubtedly a black face
whether or not she knows it but it is
most definitely not a black voice yet
i'm sure someone is giving themselves a
big diversity pat on the back
by having that modern day menstrual show
sage stepping fetch it on the airwaves
spewing her continued nonsense now let's
listen to jeff bezos's black friend van
jones after a donald trump speech
he became president of the united states
in that moment
okay
now let's be clear van and carlos are
far from being sage but there's
certainly something to be said about
wealthy and powerful white people
elevating certain voices over others
all right people
i put on my very smart news anchor fake
glasses i don't wear glasses these are
not prescription they're just fake
glasses which is what these clowns are
wearing all the time but now i look a
little smarter i sound like someone who
knows what he's talking about right that
woman everything she just said right
there was racist uh to clear it up i
said i wasn't sure if she's a guest hose
or has a show she has a weekend show she
took joy reid's weekend slot when they
upgraded joy reed to the weekday over
there okay nobody cares about the msnbc
programming i mean nobody's watching and
nobody cares but every now and again we
got to cover this this lunacy because
for the 10 people that do watch i want
to help these people you know but she's
a racist that woman she is a racist she
looks at black people sage steel van
jones etc and she sees black people who
don't behave how she wishes they behave
and she's basically saying they're not
black her line they're black faces but
they're not black voices well she also
called sage
sage steel self-hating
everything sage steel said there was
perfectly fine you know she made a true
commentary on barack obama sage steel by
the way no one hated sage steel until
last week she's been an espn reporter
for probably 15 years or so nobody hated
her until last week then last week she
just said that she didn't want espn uh
forcing people to be vaccinated that you
should make choices for yourself you
know talk to your doctor my body my
choice kind of stuff now she's a
right-wing maniac funded by white people
as this lunatic says van jones by the
way also is a liberal he is a liberal
he's too liberal for me at this point
right he's like sort of just like a bill
maher style liberal um who occasionally
reaches out to the other side right uh
he's he's had talks with candace owens
he sometimes reaches out to people on
the right i'd be happy to talk to him by
the way um
but if
imagine if a host on fox news
did what she just did there here are
black people who are sellouts thus are
not black which by the way this is what
here wait i'll i'll do it with my
glasses to make a real point
this is what
the lefty media does with all minorities
they treat them like pets okay this is
what they do you may remember when peter
thiel came out of the closet years ago
an out magazine which is a big lgbtq
elemental magazine said that he's not
gay sure he has sex with dudes but he's
not gay because being gay is about a
political ideology not simply your
sexual preference so they will take away
your sexuality just like this woman just
took away the skin color of van jones
and sage steel these are not good people
i don't like them very much
i don't like their ideas and i don't
know why they're on television and by
the way when she's talking about wealthy
white people that give these people
money and put them on tv
uh does she know she's on tv
does she know that uh msnbc is a big
corporate conglomerate that
he doesn't know connor has no freaking
idea if she knows that we don't know we
don't know
let's move on uh hillary clinton
remember her she was the woman who said
that donald trump was an illegitimate
president she said it many times in
interviews uh she still got a tweet up
that said it um she's the woman that
just passed out remember just like two
weeks before election just dropped dead
and they hid that they dragged her
carcass into the thing and said she was
fine
you know she probably killed a couple
people you know hillary you remember her
she was married to bill bill of course
is the guy who took a uh cigar and
actually stuck it up an intern while he
was on the phone uh in the oval office
uh with he was calling trent lott and he
uh well you know this is a daytime show
i don't want to tell you everything
anyway hillary clinton's back and she's
very worried about democracy people
because she is democracy like
palpatine's the senate take a look i
believe you said it's up to us to make
sure the plot stays fictional after
writing this any interest at all in
getting back into the game of politics i
will never be out of the game of
politics i'm not going to be running for
anything but i really feel amy and i
know
george was interviewing adam schiff
before
i really feel like our democracy is at
stake and there's many reasons for that
some of them we saw on
the screen with the insurrection some of
them because of the revelations about
facebook that creates a world of
disinformation instead of you know one
that we can agree on what the facts are
i really am worried about what's
happening at home and around the world
so i'm never going to get out of uh you
know being
involved worried and hopefully trying to
help in some way
you know they say wishes come true but
it's obviously not true because like
many times wished that she would just
disappear and yet she keeps reappearing
so you know i'm gonna have to switch to
another birthday wish uh but there's a
lot of nonsense that she just said there
okay so she's never going away she's not
gonna run and it's like yes you guys
never going away is why we have this
problem uh we've got 137 year old dianne
feinstein as a senator here in
california everyone knows she's
basically incapacitated at this point i
mean that's like an open secret at this
point uh you know biden is 78 and
obviously has problems nancy pelosi is
an alcoholic how old is she 80 whatever
she is it's like just let go people
forgetting that i have political
disagreements with him just let go trump
is old too so i'm not making this a
partisan thing but but the boomer
generation has to let go
they're the first generation that
refuses to just let go and let the next
generation in th the gen x people are
supposed to be running the show right
now the 45 year olds are supposed to be
running the show i don't want to run the
show but it's supposed to be people
roughly my age by the way ron desantis i
think is 43 years old just saying yes
nancy pelosi is 81 but hillary says a
couple interesting things right there
our democracy is at stake this is the
woman who said that the previous
election uh was illegitimate that you
know the orange man was illegitimate uh
but you know she gets a pass on that um
but the democracy why is it at stake
well there was the insurrection and that
is true for three hours a couple people
were cosplaying and larping and went to
the uh capitol and had no weapons and
you know it was put down they had no big
plans and you know that was that um so
that did happen i cannot deny that that
happened also facebook facebook's coming
for democracy now look you know i have
no love for big tech but facebook i mean
you saw everything that happened with
this ridiculous faux whistleblower last
week who's really a leftist activist and
the idea that facebook is destroying
democracy went in many cases not that i
sit here to defend mark zuckerberg very
often
but zuckerberg made an interesting point
last week we're basically the only one
that's doing any self-reflection trying
to figure out what we are doing we're
doing all of these surveys we're talking
to people we're trying to figure out how
to how to de-escalate some of the
political madness now i don't know if
it's working i don't even know if that's
true but it's obvious that facebook is
at some level trying to
somewhat moderate what is going on on
its platform look at twitter which is
just an endless
um
an endless cesspool of insanity
uh
that's what twitter is they're not doing
any of that right so that's not to
defend facebook but hillary is very
concerned about the insurrection and
she's very concerned about facebook now
interestingly when she says that our
democracy is at stake she doesn't seem
to be concerned that the federal
government would be attacking states
rights she doesn't seem to be worried
that we're forcing people to make
medical decisions that they don't want
to make she doesn't seem to be very
concerned that the economy is tanking
right now that inflation is going
through the roof that gas prices are
really high that a lot of people
can't afford to buy houses right now as
the housing market keeps rising and
people are losing their jobs
i don't think she meant any of that when
she said that she's worried about the
state of democracy hmm
i'm gonna have to i'm gonna have to
think about that you know what
i'm gonna have to think about that
guys part three of my interview with uh
michael schellenberger is up right now a
super interesting guy a former
progressive who saw the light his new
book
san francisco is out right now and it's
all about how progressives destroy
cities as uh rand paul said the other
day
big heart little brain that's what the
problem is with these people i could not
agree more and i'm starting to wonder
about the hard part
and for everything else if you want to
play along if you want to support the
show you want to keep us independent all
that good stuff join us at
reubenreport.locals.com we don't have
rich white people that support us like
they do over on msnbc it's you guys and
that's pretty good that's the way i like
it all right
that's great have a great day i'll see
you tomorrow